it's impossible to independently verify
these claims being made by both the
Russians and the ukrainians over what is
being reported as an escalation of
fighting in various different locations
in the East and to a certain extent
slightly South as well started with
Russia's claim Russian military saying
that they had repelled what they
described as a large-scale Ukrainian
operation trying to push into areas that
Russia occupied in the southern Donetsk
region they supplied what they said was
Russian Drone footage showing a green
field with military vehicles in that
field being targeted some of them
exploding but as I say impossible to
confirm whether indeed those Vehicles
were actually Ukrainian
meanwhile there have been claims being
made by the leader of the Russian
mercenary group Wagner Mr if Guinea
pregosian a very angry recorded message
that he left on it on a telegram Channel
saying that Russian forces were being
forced to withdraw from a village called
berkev go now that is north of bank
and the village of berkiefka we
understand we're taking full control of
by the Russians only last month
meanwhile Ukrainian side are saying that
they've made small games south of bakmud
pushing up
um towards the city again independently
verification to independently verify
this very difficult indeed I think
what's also important to mention is
increasing chatter by some pro-russian
military bloggers on telegram channels
they're talking specifically about a
town called Novo donetsky which was in
controlled by the Russians they're
saying that there is at least one
possibly two Ukrainian fronts moving
towards that town one blogger saying
that the Russians had already lost
around two kilometers of territory there
another saying that there was evidence
of the German Leopard two tanks being
used in this operation but as I say very
difficult to independently verify and we
do not expect any kind of a fish
statement by the ukrainians as to
whether this fighting represents a start
to this long-awaited Ukrainian
counter-offensive